we have breaking news overnight from
California and it's heartbreaking police
have found the bodies of a family of
four that had been kidnapped earlier
this week Merced County officials say
they found the Singh family in a very
rural area late last night the youngest
victim was just eight months old they
were found the same day that a video was
released showing a masked man kidnapping
the family members from their trucking
business at gunpoint Carter Evans has
more on this horrific crime that police
call senseless
uh tonight our worst fears have been
confirmed uh we found
the four people from the kidnapping and
they are in fact deceased Merced County
Sheriff Vern warnke was visibly upset
overnight addressing the media on a
remote Dirt Road in Northern California
near where the discovery was made
there's just there's no words right now
to describe the anger I feel and the
senselessness of this incident warduki
says a farm worker discovered the bodies
of jazz deep Singh his eight-month-old
daughter and her mother as well as Jazz
Deep's brother amandeep in an orchard
Wednesday night the development comes as
the Singh's family had been desperate
for answer since the four went missing
Monday earlier they pleaded with the
public for help everybody whoever have
the cameras please check the camera if
you guys have any helpful tip or video
please provide it to the Sheriff's
Department on Wednesday police released
this surveillance video it shows a
masked man leading the brothers at
gunpoint from a building to a pickup
truck Monday morning their hands zip
tied behind their backs he then comes
back for the baby and her mother police
say the suspect is 48-year-old Jesus
Salgado he was tracked down after
investigators say he used one of the
victim's ATM cards and then attempted to
take his own life Salgado was convicted
in 2007 for attempted false imprisonment
and a home invasion robbery with a gun
he was paroled eight years later
investigators haven't found a link
between the suspect and the Singh family
and they're still searching for a motive
I'm just living inside because this was
completely totally senseless we have a
whole family left out and for what we
don't know yet for CBS mornings I'm
Carter Evans in Los Angeles
this is one of those stories
unfortunately that we have to tell but I
just don't want to act like we tell the
story and just move on to the next right
this whole block has been really
upsetting when you think about the the
shooting from the police officer to the
little children to now that story where
there's no apparent link yeah I I just
don't want to act like this is that we
know this is not a normal day and this
is very very hard and upsetting there's
just evil in this world that is hard to
come together but you can't explain yeah
you can't explain it okay okay